we're told that millions of americans
rely on caffeine to get them up in the
morning which is true although if i
drink caffeine in the morning i'm very
sensitive i wouldn't be able to sleep at
night here's nutritional data on some
popular drinks at ben's beans coffee
shop
all right so here we have the different
names of the drinks and then here we
have the type of the drink and it looks
like they're either hot or cold here we
have the calories for each of those
drinks here we have the sugar content in
grams for each of those drinks and here
we have the caffeine in milligrams for
each of those drinks
and then we are asked the individuals in
this data set are
and we have three choices
ben's beans customers ben's beans drinks
or the caffeine contents now we have to
be careful when someone says the
individuals in a data set they don't
necessarily mean that they have to be
people they could be things and the
individuals in this data set
each of these rows they're referring to
a certain type of drink at ben's beans
coffee shops so the different types of
drinks that ben b ben's beans offers
those are the individuals in this data
set
so they're ben's beans drinks
next they ask us the data set contains
and they say how many variables and how
many of those variables are categorical
so if we look up here let's look at the
variables so this first column that's
essentially giving us the the type of
drink this wouldn't be a variable this
would be more of an identifier but all
of these other columns are representing
variables so for example type is a
variable it can either be hot or cold
and because it can only take on one of
kind of a
a number of buckets it's either going to
be hot or cold it's going to fit in one
category or another and you don't just
have two categories you could have more
than two categories but it isn't just
some type of variable number that can
take on a bunch of different values so
this right over here is a categorical
variable calories is not a categorical
variable you could have something with
4.1 calories you could have something
with a 178 things aren't fitting into
nice buckets same thing for sugars and
for the caffeine that these are
quantitative variables that don't just
fit into a category and so here i would
say that we have four variables one two
three four one of which is categorical
so that would be
choice a over here